the fastest way to get what you want in
life is to model success be super clear
on what you want out of life and then go
find people who've accomplished exactly
that and learn from them who you spend
your time with is who you become so
Choose Wisely because most people wake
up like an accident instead of actually
chasing down their dreams and it starts
with modeling success I've been a big
believer in my own success ever since my
very first business it's why I continue
to do what I do I I tell the story Bill
Gates saved my first company I I haven't
met him yet hopefully will get to shake
his hand and tell him the impact that he
had in my first business I was making no
money and I and I wanted to quit on my
company and I told my business partner
that I quit and I felt like I had tried
everything I tried everything it wasn't
for lack of effort every day I woke up
and new ideas came into my head and I
tried them and nothing was working hey
it's Nina Cara Michael and like Evan
Carmichael says the fastest way to get
what you want in life is to model
success and that's why we made these
videos to help you find the fastest his
way to get what you want in life to
model success
[Music]
me motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation
you know that feeling when you're just
trying Non-Stop and nothing is working
and the frustration that comes over you
to feel like
I feel worthless I felt worthless as a
human that I that I wasn't contributing
that I was just putting all this effort
in and just nothing was happening and
that led to me quitting on my business
partner and the next day I woke up and I
said I can't quit I'm gonna regret it if
I quit right now
but I have to find another way like this
is it's not this is not working right
now and then I I just realized I'm not
the first guy to try to sell software
before somebody's figured this out right
somebody's gone through this process I
can learn from them and and maybe apply
that strategy to my company and maybe
it'll work
and I thought of the only person I can
think of at the time was Bill Gates
I had a biotech software company he
didn't have biotech it was something
else but I mean I'm at this point it was
it was bought on the barrel I'm willing
to try anything right now
and I looked at how we started this
company went from zero to one and it was
through Partnerships and so I applied
that strategy to my business and and
shortly thereafter closed my first
partnership deal that paid us thirteen
and a half thousand dollars and that was
a lot of money for me because I was only
making 300 bucks a month at that time
and that gave me hope and ever since
then whenever I don't know what to do in
any area in life in business and
relationships or anything
I asked myself who's done this thing and
it's recognizing that nobody is the
perfect person there's no one person you
can learn everything from
but there's different pieces from
different people so when you're super
clear on what you want when it's really
easy to know this is what I want in my
business this is what I want in my
relationship this is what I want in my
career this is what I want in my this
specific thing I want to be a salsa
dancer like him and I want to be a
YouTuber like her and I want to be a
real estate investor like him
then that's what you learn from that
person
modern success is the fastest way to get
you where you need to be understand that
you don't have to be a genius at
everything the the path before you has
already been figured out it's already
been done by other people and as the
famous quote goes success leaves Clues
you have to start looking for them all
right how do I set a success what is my
three-step process as somebody who's
maybe done it more than any other person
at least definitely within a YouTube
environment here we go step number one
is get super clear on what you want what
do you want what kind of business Do you
want to build and inside of that what
kind of marketer do you want to be what
kind of operations manager do you want
to be what kind of leader do you want to
be and understanding that those may be
different skill sets that you learn from
different people right I want to be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs I want to
believe in people like AP janini I want
to be a father like my father I want to
stand up for my principles like Howard
Schultz I wanna I wanna know that now is
the time to be the greatest me like
Kanye West you're pulling different
things from different people
if you start to Mush it all together
that's when you lose Clarity or if I say
I just want to be like Steve Jobs
that's not great because there's a lot
of things I don't want to be from seed I
don't want to be a father like Steve
Jobs there's things that I don't want to
be from different people the goal is to
be the best Evan Carmichael and you
can't get that by just following one
person but you take different little
pieces from different people when you're
super clear
so you have to get super clear on what
you want out of life
what kind of person do you want to be
write it down and be super clear step
number two is find the people who have
it so who's done it this is what you
want in a life great go out and start
researching who's done it so if I want
to build a successful software company
who's done it Bill Gates did it great
let me go learn from him
right let me understand how he did it
let me go read the early days of how he
got started right not not so much how he
does it now but how do they get started
so for each of those categories who has
done it one of the things that helped me
free myself from being sick all the time
was I studied Wim Hof
I used to get sick all the time I was
sick all the time I would have a belief
system that if somebody was sick if Alex
got sick he's like Alex don't come don't
come near me don't come over today work
from home I don't want to see you
because I'm going to get sick and I
would get sick every month I was sick I
get sick now maybe once a year
it's crazy why because I I decided to
study after after being so fed up with
having four days of hiccups that I
couldn't get rid of it's pretty
embarrassing I was hiccuping for four
days I couldn't get rid of it and I
decided I'm I'm just I need to get
healthy who's done this
and I came across Wim Hof great I'm
gonna learn from Wim Hof and I'm gonna
learn how to not get sick again
I don't necessarily want to be an
entrepreneur like Wim Hof there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that I
probably don't want to learn from him
how awesome how to not get sick I want
to learn that from him
so be super clear on what you want to
learn and then find the people who are
the best in the world at that one thing
and that's who you're gonna study and
then set number three is live in their
world so if you want to learn Italian
the fastest way is to go to Italy you'll
you'll be forced to learn it
chances are whatever you want to learn
whoever you want to become like the
people that you want to hang around with
and spend time and be the next Visionary
like Steve Jobs right those people are
not in your environment right now
and so if you just get this little micro
dose once a month it's not going to be
enough if you just watch one whim hop
video it's not gonna be enough right you
might have this one little moment that's
amazing but then it's not consistent
enough you have to live in their world
so for me I I've done it by creating
these channels I force myself to be in
people's worlds by creating I'm not
hanging around Grant Cardone every day
I'm not hanging around garyvee or Tony
Robbins or Ed mylett every day right
I've connected with these people I've
I've met a good chunk of them we've done
content and hung out but I'm not with
them every day so it's easy to fall back
to where you were so I force it through
my content I force it through my
business I force it through the YouTube
channel that I'm making
now you could do it for yourself as well
whatever you want to learn and be more
like be around it be it have it in your
world I look at the Wim Hof stuff and
when I was going through his uh app and
and the material I was doing it very
consistently but because Wim Hof wasn't
a part of my environment every day I
fell off I wasn't doing the breathing as
much I wasn't doing the cold showers as
much and so what did I do I printed a
giant poster it's in my bathroom I would
take you back there but my camera is
stuck on a tripod this giant poster of
Wim Hof I subscribe to his YouTube
channel so anytime he has a new video
coming up it's a trigger it's a reminder
yeah ah right I need to do that again
because you're gonna forget you're gonna
fall back to your old habits in your old
ways and your old thinking patterns you
need to be shifted into the new one and
that happens by living in their world so
follow them on Instagram follow them on
YouTube put something up on your wall to
remind you of it every single day of
that thing that you're trying to become
because that thing that you want to
become is the best version of you so we
got super clear on what best version of
you looks like
you've now identified who's done it and
now you're living in their world and
that doesn't mean you have to follow a
thousand people but different people for
different things to help you be the best
you rule number two find your own path
people don't know what balance is for
them
I mean so many entrepreneurs who want to
be like Kevin O'Leary or Mark Cuban or
Elon Musk and build these giant
businesses what they're not willing to
do the sacrifices that go along with it
if you look at their personal lives you
probably don't want to be like them I
look at Steve Jobs who's on my wall at
home and I want to be a Visionary like
him but I don't want to be a father like
him right I don't want to put in that
amount of work and then not be present
for my family the key is figuring out
what balance looks like for you what a
successful life looks like for you and
that may mean that you don't go and
build a billion dollar company
what does life look like for you we're
constantly judging ourselves based off
of other people's schedules based off of
other people's results and saying I
can't do everything I want to be like
this and like that and like this and
like that and like this like that and
having no clear picture for what an what
a complete picture looks like for you
that's a problem
you can't look like the Rock and build a
billion dollar business and be the
greatest father in the world and right
like you have to pick you have to
understand what balance looks like for
you and not judge yourself against other
people's version of balance period
what I like doing
personally is what I call trying on hats
so I will look at what other people are
doing and use it as source of
inspiration as opposed to judgment
against myself how poor I'm doing right
what most people will do is you'll look
at somebody like Kevin O'Leary and say
man look at what he's doing I I suck I
can't do that I'm not working hard
enough I look at that as inspiration as
I have to try on to say maybe I can do
this and I and then I try it but my goal
isn't to be the next Kevin O'Leary my
goal is to be the best Evan Carmichael
right my goal isn't to be the next rock
or Steve Jobs or anybody else is to be
the best Evan Carmichael and you get
that by trying on other people's hats
it's not going to quite fit their
schedule won't quite fit working out for
four hours a day like the rock does that
may not fit and it doesn't like you look
at me that's why I don't look like the
rock because I'm not working out four
hours a day you have to try on their hat
see how it fits see how you like it make
the tweaks and adjustment to get the
perfect thing for you and then when you
when you found your version of balance
you're less likely to be pulled in a
million different directions for what
other people expect of you and for what
other people out there are doing and you
feel crappy about yourself because
you're not doing enough
so here's a quick example
right now I'm filming this uh at the
beginning of January and my son has an
extra week of Christmas break
everybody else is back to work and I am
doing a hybrid right now so most kids
get two weeks off he's got three weeks
off I am spending half my day
with him
having fun doing doing father son things
and half my day working so the morning
I'm here right now filming videos for
you Nina is in Costco can we see the
Costco sign there see Nina's in Costco
there's Costco
I'm filming I'm starting in the morning
making YouTube videos for you guys and
in the afternoon I'm going to be with
with my son I want to do that I'm okay
with that I'm missing opportunities
right now I could be making content all
day long and those videos maybe the
video that I would have made this
afternoon is one that gets 10 million
views Blues views and blows up my
channel right like maybe that happens
I'm okay with that I'm okay with
spending time with my son I want to do
that I'm not following through with
people that I should I can leave that
until next week I'm not making content
on my Instagram like I normally would uh
because I want to spend time with my son
and that's my version of balance and and
I'm okay with that and you can judge me
and say that's a wrong decision or you
can judge me and say that's a great
decision either way I don't care because
I'm living my version of balance I'm
proud of myself for my actions and
that's all that matters are you proud of
yourself for how you are living your
life period when you go home when you
look at yourself in the mirror are you
proud of today are you proud of what you
did are you proud of how you spent your
time
your version of balance may not be
perfect not yet and listen mine isn't
either I'm constantly tweaking
constantly hacking constantly learning
constantly adjusting because even if you
found your perfect version of balance
it's going to adjust right it's gonna
adjust next year won't be the same five
years definitely won't be the same and
so it's find those little micro tweaks
and adjustments but the most important
thing is understanding what are your
goals what are your Ambitions not just
business we tend to focus entrepreneurs
we tend to focus just on our business
here's my goals for this year here's my
goals for where I want to be in the next
five years right you set your goals
but you don't have the same structure
for your family you don't have the same
structure for your for your life look at
your schedule
look in your schedule how many of the
things in your schedule are business
things
have you scheduled your family time do
you treat that as important as you would
a business meeting
so I schedule in my time with my wife I
protect it if something is going to go
against it for example Saturdays I spend
with Nina
I haven't done every single Saturday
some opportunities have come up
but if I'm going to move something on a
Saturday I have to talk to Nina about it
and it's got to be an important
opportunity otherwise left to my own
devices I would just work all the time
right I love it I love my work I'm
obsessed with my work I love making
videos for you guys I love responding to
the comments like I love I love I love I
love what I do if Nina's out on a Friday
night with her friends 85 chance I'm
just going to be working
because it's not work because it's it's
love it's enjoyment it's fulfillment
it's service it's all the great stuff
for me
but then when I step above it that's my
addiction right like entrepreneurship
helping you guys is my addiction when I
step above it doing that 24 7 actually
doesn't lead to me having
the life that I want because I want to
be a good father and I want to be a good
husband and I want to take care of
myself physically so those other things
you have to schedule into your calendar
don't just schedule in the business
things you schedule in your life so that
when you step above this is a great
exercise for the next week create your
life schedule for the next week that
when you step above when you say okay
yes I'm going to wake up and I'm gonna
I'm gonna work out or I'm gonna watch
those videos or I'm going to spend this
time with my wife or a husband or
boyfriend girlfriend or children or
parents right whatever you need for your
life if you need to call your mom every
day schedule that in if you need to hang
out with your family every weekend
schedule that in right whatever is super
important to you if you have to watch
the game every Sunday schedule that in
put it on your calendar
that leads to a happy life for you
what is your version of balance that's
all that matters your version of balance
to create the best you that when you
step above when you look at your
calendar and say if I did these things I
would be a happy successful fulfilled
person period
and when you've done that
when you've created that
then have the courage to step into it
and live it regardless of what the
people around you are judging you for
because you're always going to get
judgment
some people say you're doing way too
much and some people say you're not
doing enough you're building your
business some people will say you're
working way too hard and other people
will say you're barely you're barely
starting keep going like you call this
work
right somebody's always going to have an
opinion on what you should be doing with
your life
and until you determine you figure out
you understand what balance looks like
for you to create a happy successful
fulfilled life on your own terms write
it down and then create your calendar
and then stick to your calendar and if
other people are judging you for it you
thank them for their opinion but you let
it bounce off you because you're happy
and they're not rule number three build
your confidence whoever is more
confident wins when you're hanging
around somebody Whoever has more
confidence is going to be the person who
influences and persuades the other
person and this is for all areas of your
life if you're hanging around people who
are confident that you will not be
successful and you're lacking confidence
in your success guess what their
confidence in how unsuccessful you're
going to be
will breed into you and you'll feel like
you can't do it on the flip side if
you're hanging around people who believe
in you who make you feel amazing guess
what their confidence in you their
belief in you will help you believe more
in yourself
this applies the health and fitness if
you're hanging around people who are
always working out who are eating
healthy who are taking care of their
body they're more confident in their
health than you are in your lack of
health and you're going to become
healthier you're going to start to eat
better you're going to start to work out
more just by osmosis just by you being
around them just through proximity
that's it period you will become that
you will become like the people who you
spend the most time with so when Ed
mylett invited me to his home he's got a
beautiful home just outside of San Diego
and he invited me over I spent the the
evening there and
if I spent more one-on-one time with Ed
I've left that night feeling
amazing bold confident ready to take on
my big goals the Big Dreams like let's
go
he's got a beautiful environment he's
got a beautiful family uh you know
beautiful house
just motivating as ever and that that
evening I spent with him
made me feel like I could do anything
if I spent more time with Ed then I'm
sure I would be even more successful I'd
have a bigger impact I'd be reaching
more people I'd be making more money I'd
be I'd be way more successful than I am
already right now if I spent more time
with that we talked a lot about Ed's
YouTube and I'm sure if Ed spent more
time with me his YouTube channel would
be blowing up even more than it already
is because I'm more confident in YouTube
than he is and he's more confident in
the things that he's great at than I am
and so by us spending more time together
we will both get better at the things
that we're less confident in
when I went to an event in uh just
outside of Los Angeles I met Charlie who
runs Charisma on commands another
awesome YouTube channel if you haven't
seen it go check it out and Charlie was
working out every day going for runs
every day whenever we met and had dinner
he was always eating super clean uh
always eating fish and salad with no
dressing like really looking after
himself and for me at that time any time
that I traveled I kind of use that as my
out as my excuse to say okay it doesn't
matter if I'm as healthy as I am when I
get back I'll get I'll have these four
days away and then I'll be fine when I
come back so I'd be eating junk and
pizza and burgers and and everything
else
if I spent more time with Charlie I
would be healthier
you know and in that that micro window
that we had him just eating salmon and
going for runs every day made me want to
be healthier and if we had more
proximity I'd be even healthier than I
am right now because he's more confident
in his health and routines than I am
and so this is really important because
a lot of this is happening in the
background you're not even noticing it
you're not even paying attention to it
if you are around successful people you
would by default become more successful
if you're around healthier people you'll
by default become healthier it just will
happen without you even thinking about
it you'll be pulled there automatically
because they're more confident in that
area of their life than you are the
problem is most of us have people in our
Lives who are not happy not successful
not fulfilled not Purpose Driven not
healthy they have the potential they're
good people they're just not living the
life that they want to live they don't
have a high degree of confidence that
life is possible they actually have a
high degree of confidence that things
are not possible
and so if you are the most ambitious
person in your circle that you're around
that's a problem because you're the one
giving hope giving belief giving
confidence to other people but who's
doing it for you
and it's probably not the people
currently in your life or maybe you have
a few special people and that you've got
those people hold on to them real tight
because you really really really need to
have that and so knowing that that's
what happens right knowing that that
this is the way that that your life is
shaped now how can we do it with more
intention so two ideas that I've got for
you and and if you do this
if you actually apply this to your life
things will start to change dramatically
for the better for you for the money you
make for the impact that you have the
service you can create for your health
for your happiness all of it step number
one is start to really look at the
people in your life
people who you spend the most time with
the closest proximity
how much are they sucking your energy or
giving you energy how much are they
inspiring you how confident are they in
your success and trying to spend as much
time as possible with the people who are
giving you energy we don't have that
many people who give us energy
you probably don't have that many people
that after you spend time with them
you're feeling more pumped up more bold
more confident more courageous more
willing to go off and and Seize the Day
right when you leave them when you
finish that coffee with them or get off
the phone call or Zoom call with them
you leave them are you ready to seize
the day
or do you feel tired worn out burnt out
stressed out because you took on all of
their problems and you gave them a great
gift and you're trying to encourage
motivate and Inspire them but you don't
feel better you might feel better
because you serve which is great but you
don't feel more energetic to go off and
Seize the Day on a big scale
when you find those people you have to
spend more time with and you have to
find a way to spend more time you have
to you have to you have to you have to
be the one to reach out to put something
on the calendar to schedule it in so
that you're spending more time with the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and that that may not be uh you
know Ed by level right I only went to
Ed's house once I haven't been back to
San Diego since and
um when I do go back hopefully he
invites me over again
so I'm not calling Ed every week but
trying to find ways to spend more time
with the people who lift you up even if
it's
somebody who who is a an acquaintance
somebody who don't know super well but
every time you're around them you feel
better like try to put a regular coffee
schedule in your calendar with them
even if it feels super awkward even if
you have to say hey
this might sound super weird but every
time we get together every time I'm
around you I leave feeling
better about myself I leave feeling
ready to go in seize the day and I have
more confidence and boldness and there's
just something about
you that makes that come out in me and
I'm super grateful I'm wondering if you
just want to do a if you're down for a
coffee once a month
and we could talk about our business we
could talk about books for reading or
videos we're watching and just share
them
seem may seem like it's coming out of
left field but what do you think
and then see what they say
put that on your list and spend more
time with those people second thing is
what I call aspirational mentors
so
I believe that you can learn a lot from
people even if you never meet them that
you can have proximity by spending time
with them through their videos through
their books through their podcasts I've
learned a lot through my own videos
through watching Ed mylett top 10 videos
I learn a lot I can still have Ed in my
environment even if I had never known
him even if I had never met him you can
still learn a lot from Ed by watching
his YouTube channel by reading his book
by listening to his podcast you can
learn a lot from him you're still around
him is it as good as being in his house
in San Diego getting the one-on-one
coaching no
but is it better than just turning on
Netflix and being entertained absolutely
if you watched an ed mylett video every
day
you are slowly going to start to think
more like Ed mylett you are slowly going
to start to see the world like Ed mylett
and apply that for anybody Tony Robbins
somebody in Health and Fitness Nutrition
and diet like whatever it is that you
want to get great at
put it as a part of your calendar
schedule that time in I like videos the
best I'm a visual learner so for me it
would be watching the videos of somebody
it's why I have so many channels because
I want to consume the content
and then share with you but it helps me
these are the aspirational mentors in my
life I can learn a lot from a Steve Jobs
even though I will never meet him
because of the video content that he has
produced and interviews that he's been
on
you can choose to inject that into your
life so step one are real life people
who you can meet and have coffee with
and learn from and connect with but step
two are aspirational mentors who you may
meet at some point but may never meet
but you can still learn a lot from them
you can still be inspired by them and if
again this is this happens not in these
one-off big moments it's daily it's
daily you need to create in your
calendar a daily time to be around the
people who inspire you the most I would
look at
everybody who has inspired you at some
point make a list of all the books
you've read or videos that you watch for
me it's it's videos that I've watched
make a list of them of the people
and then put that into your daily
Calendar create a schedule of 30 videos
for the next 30 days that you're gonna
watch
in your morning routine with intention
not while you're vacuuming because
people don't vacuum us that's a weird
thing you vacuum is pretty important
routine not while you're brushing your
teeth
or making your baby doing something else
but with intention you're going to sit
down and have your coffee or or have
your breakfast and watch the video with
intention to learn from this person
because you want to start to think to
act to adopt the mindset of the ad
mylettes of the Oprah Winfrey's of the
Elon Musk or Steve Jobs or whoever it is
again that inspires you to be the best
you think about the people who gave you
the most energy and then be around them
even if it's just virtually through
video every single day those two things
it'll dramatically shift your life
forward if you stay with the people who
are in your life right now you will stay
where you are right now
if you shift it to start cutting out or
limiting access to the people who make
you feel worse about yourself and
injecting more people who make you feel
better about yourself and then
supplementing that with the aspirational
mentors of the people who lift you to a
higher Stratosphere every single day
one year from today your life will be
dramatically different but only if you
do it on an every single day basis make
it happen I'm excited to see you change
rule number four shift if your beliefs
your next big step forward in life will
come from a big shift in perspective on
one of your beliefs your habits your
routines the results that you're getting
all come from what you believe to be
true about your life and the world and
for you to get different results than
you're getting right now in your life
you're going to have to change your
perspective on one or more of your
beliefs so this topics makes me think
about my favorite comment of all time if
you think about my YouTube channel I've
had it for 11 years and I don't know how
many thousands of thousands of comments
my favorite comment of all time was we
profiled a black entrepreneur and
one of the guys in the comments said
growing up my parents taught me that
black people were the n-word
and you just changed my perspective
today I was willing to learn from a
black man
and
it blew my mind because when I first set
out to make my channel uh it wasn't
really about race or willingness to
learn from other people it was it was
more hey these people have accomplished
success you should go and learn from
them I wasn't set out to try to solve
sexism or racism or anything uh so big
like that
but what had happened was I had enough
credibility with this person and I
didn't know them from anything they just
watched enough of my videos that then
when I made this video on a black man he
decided you know what I'm gonna give it
a few minutes and that experience
changed his perspective that then we'll
hopefully go off and change his life
imagine having that belief that then
changes what kind of ripple effect that
has on the rest of your life and that's
what happens when you get exposed to New
Opportunities and new people and New
Perspectives you you were raised with a
perspective
your parents your family community a
super isolated perspective that you feel
is right and many of those things may
still be right for who you want to
become but if you want to have greater
success greater levels of confidence
greater levels of happiness and purpose
and fulfillment than the people around
you you're gonna have to believe
something that's different than what
they believe you're gonna have to
surround yourself with other people
who've actually gone off and done that
thing because the people around you
aren't giving you the thing that you
need and so that's one of my main goals
with this channel I know people come in
to learn from people who are like them
you learn from people who who look like
you who might be the same sex or same
gender and the same industry or use the
same language as you
but what I'm really hoping to do as well
is in that process you came for this one
person you came for this one thought or
one idea and I want to expose you to a
whole bunch of different perspectives
all still within the lens of belief
right everything on my channels all of
the channels are always positive it's
always believed it's always optimistic
it's always uplifting but I want to try
to hit you with different perspectives
and angles because Eric Thomas and Jaco
willink are gonna yell at you through
something and Oprah Winfrey and Wayne
Dyer are gonna hug you through something
and sometimes maybe you need to yell and
sometimes you need to hug but I want to
give you different perspectives to help
you become the best version of you okay
so how do I make the perspective shifts
that we need to make in our life to get
to the spot that we want to be I've got
a three-step process let's go step
number one is learn to learn from people
that you hate
this is one of the most important things
that I can that I can articulate that I
can push you towards find somebody who's
had success
ideally in some kind of related field
but still has some success that you hate
for some reason
and force yourself to learn from them
force yourself to find one thing about
them that you can learn to make you
better at what to do so even looking at
my wall here right I like to tell the
story I've got I've got Steve Jobs here
and I got my dad here I want to be a
Visionary like Steve Jobs and a father
like my father I don't want to be a
father like Steve Jobs as an a Visionary
like my dad right the whole point of
this is for you to be the best you and
for that to happen you pull different
things from different people
you may Hate Everything About Steve Jobs
or everything about Kanye West at the
back wall there but there's but there's
one thing there's one thing that you can
learn from that person to help you be
better that's often a thing that unlocks
a huge chunk of learning
people typically lock themselves in a
box you've trapped yourself in a box of
learning of saying I'm only going to
learn from these kinds of people and so
you get the same kind of messages over
and over and over again but really if
you want to unlock your learning
finding people who you disagree with who
you may hate you may hate a lot about
them but examining how they've had
success a good starting point is the top
tens on my other channel right it's
always positive it's something that I've
learned from if I can learn from them
you could probably learn from them as
well there's one little nugget out of
those 10 rules maybe that can apply to
your life and when I was learning from
Kanye West Kanye West was somebody who's
to bother me a lot I saw somebody who's
got a giant ego somebody who who I I
didn't want to be like but I realized
you know what I can learn from this guy
I can learn from this guy I can learn to
think bigger like Kanye I could learn to
be a better friend if you know the story
of him and John Legend I can learn to be
a better friend like Kanye that you
can't really see that picture there but
he's on a radio interview and and he's
saying In that clip uh the time is now
to be the greatest you I don't want to
sit inside a corporation for the next 30
Years like this is the time the time is
now let's go I believe that I need to
remember that even more like the time is
now not tomorrow not in three years not
next month like it's right now the time
is now free you can learn that from
Kanye right now even if you hate him so
step number one is find somebody who you
hate go to my top 10 Channel or my main
Channel and go back in the archives and
find somebody who you see their picture
and it drives you nuts already great
force yourself to go learn one thing
from that person that's the starting
point for shifting your perspective step
number two is say it's the best it's the
best this is one of the most valuable
perspective shifts that I think any
human can make is when you're faced with
something that's negative something that
that most people complain of and the old
you used to complain about you shifted
and say this is the best this is the
best this thing has happened to me right
now that's the best this coronavirus is
happening right now for me it's the best
shift your perspective to say this is
the best because what it does is it
moves you from a place of being
complaining and upset and angry and
unproductive into a place of possibility
of resourcefulness of you now showing to
yourself and to the world what you're
capable of and so when I broke my neck
when when there's a fire alarm going off
when we have Corona this is this is how
I stay productive this is how I stay
focused this is how I stay pushing
forward when most people are complaining
and negative is I tell myself this is
the best
this is my chance this is an opportunity
and I think this is this is the one of
the biggest things that entrepreneurs
who've had the biggest success Crush at
so many entrepreneurs have built their
businesses the ones that you look up to
and respect and admire and want to be
like they built their businesses in the
toughest times they build their
businesses in recessions and depressions
why because they said it's the best so
whatever that thing is it feels
overwhelming all all-encompassing
negative in your life stop complaining
about it and say this is the best I'm
growing I'm getting stronger through
this adversity I'm going to make
something amazing as a result of it and
step number three is the first time yes
rule the first time yes rule is the
first time you get invited to something
or an idea comes your head say yes
most people are in the no business most
people are looking at all the reasons
why it's not going to work and you can't
do this and you have no skills or
abilities or time or resources you're
always finding those we're in the no
business of what we can't do stuff we've
told ourselves we can't do these things
just say yes the first time
this is one of the things I love most
about my wife Nina is all come with all
sorts of crazy ideas and the first time
she'll say yes
we'll see right you want to drive to to
Boston with with two videographers in
the back and film yes perfect you want
to go to satguru in Philadelphia and
spend two days meditate yes perfect you
will even though you hate the cold you
wanna sit in an ice bath with Wim Hof
when it comes to Toronto and fill me yes
perfect doesn't mean she's gonna do it
again she hasn't sat in a nice bath
since but it's the first time yes the
first time yes rule is one of the
biggest mentality shifts that if you can
make you'll open yourself up to so many
more opportunities I look at dancing for
example trying to dance salsa right the
other another business that I run and
operate
the number of people who come in
and are scared and super nervous and
it's their first time dancing ever as an
adult and then you see the shift that
they make in the identity of like I just
did that
I danced I never thought I could dance
and here I got a few basic steps of a
move and if they keep coming back
they'll keep getting better
a lot of times you're not making the
perspective shift that you need because
you're not trying enough new stuff
because you're in the no business first
time yes rule you get an idea somebody
asks you for something somebody wants to
try something with you yes first time
yes doesn't mean you keep doing it and
as long as it doesn't go against your
ethics or your values that don't go rob
a bank because they said first time yes
okay we're not talking about that kind
of stuff
but when you feel a little bit outside
your comfort zone is like I'm not the
kind of person who does that
first time yes rule just see you might
surprise yourself also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five choose to be in
control you are always in control of how
you feel you're always in control you
may not be in control of the world and
the results that are happening and how
people are acting around you but you are
always in control you can be you can
choose to be in control of how you feel
there's the great quote that there's
nothing either good nor bad but thinking
makes it so
when something happens you have a choice
right your subconscious mind can take
over and I'll get I'm going to give you
a super important hack in this video on
how to do it
but you have a choice you can at any
time choose to see that thing that
happened as a negative or positive the
problem is we let our subconscious mind
take over we let our stories and our
patterns take over and we let that take
us into the negative and when you're in
the negative you're not productive
you're not happy you're not fulfilled
you're not in action mode you're not
building momentum and you don't hit your
goals
how do you override the subconscious
mind how do you get into that positive
place when you are in a negative place
this is really important because when
you're watching maybe a video like this
or when you're inspired you don't need
it as much right when you're inspired
and you're ready to go
you're you're on fire you're taking
action nothing can stop you you've had
these moments where you felt super
fulfilled whether it's meeting somebody
or watching video or listening to a a
podcast or reading a book you had these
moments that you felt amazing and then
what did you do you went to work and
when something bad happened you just
overcame and kept going but it's when
you're in the in the depths when you're
not feeling great when something really
bad happens to you what do you do
here's the hack that I use that if you
can apply this consistently it will
change your life it will change your
life it's catching those those down
moments and saying three words
three simple words it's
the
best
it's the best anytime you find yourself
complaining it's the best anytime you
find yourself in a negative situation
it's the best anytime you find yourself
stressed overwhelmed out of control it's
the best it's the best it's the best
tell yourself it's the best
and we're trying to rewire our
subconscious mind and you won't catch it
all the time and don't judge yourself
for catching it all the time but if you
can catch it once and you can catch it
again the next day and you can catch it
three times the next day you're gonna
start to train yourself you're gonna
start to catch it more often you're
gonna start catching it instead of one
percent of the time four percent of the
time to twenty percent of the time to 50
of the time you'll catch it more because
you're building the muscle of catching
it it's the best why
why is it the best
well again there's nothing either good
nor bad but thinking makes itself you
can choose to see the best in any
situation
I've used this for small things and big
things so even today so today
in the morning I decided to do a whole
bunch of squats
my legs were burning me right after that
I take the dogs out for their morning
walk and what I've been doing in the
morning is after I take the dogs for a
walk I climb up 13 flights of stairs
holding both my dogs I got these two
little dogs they're maybe 12 pounds each
and I hold one under each arm and I walk
up the stairs
my legs were Jello at the start and I
remember getting to the sixth floor
oh my gosh I don't know if I can do this
my legs are Jello these dogs are heavy
they feel like a thousand pounds I just
want to quit I just want to get on the
elevator and go all the way up to the
13th floor I uh this the voice in my
head tells me well but I already did all
the squats we find our way out right we
give ourselves logical reasons logical
outs from situations I did all these
squats
so that kind of counts right I mean I
don't normally do squats in the morning
I did them here that that should count
as as half the The Climb of stairs right
like no no no no no no no this is this
is the practice this is the best this
right now is the best this is my chance
to show myself what I'm made of that
those extra seven flights of stairs do
not own me
and even if I'm walking at half pace I'm
gonna get to the 13th floor
this is this is the debate inside my own
head as I'm climbing the stairs and this
seems trivial right this is this is not
a big deal this is one off what happens
does it really matter but
in those moments when you want to quit
when you want to give yourself the out
when you want to to play small when
you're giving yourself that excuse for
not doing it
how you react becomes super important
this is another small little battle that
I want by going all the way up to the
13th floor and then hitting 13 and
opening the door that feeling of of
pride of belief in myself because I
overcame the difficult thing you want to
build self-confidence you have to do
difficult things every time you go up
against something that is difficult that
is hard that is scary and you're
battling yourself and then you get
through it and you do it whether you get
a great result or not that wasn't my
best climb up but that I can that I
continued and then I finished it that I
got there
that makes you feel great about yourself
that's how you build the self-confidence
self-love self-respect by doing the
difficult things by having that inner
debate with yourself and then choosing
the path of the path of growth choosing
that path of growth instead of choosing
a smaller path and letting yourself off
the hook because other people might look
at you and say what a great job you're
doing how hard you're pushing yourself
and maybe you're pushing yourself too
hard but they just have lower standards
than you this is the battle with
yourself to be proud of yourself
it's the best so this is my this is my
fastest hack my fastest way to get into
growth Evan
proud Evan believe Evan that when I find
myself complaining about something
negative in my life I say this is the
best this is the best this is my chance
to show myself in the world whoever
Carmichael is and what does that do well
one it's a it's a little mental trick
because even just doing that even if you
just say that say you can practice it
right now say out loud this is the best
think about some negative situation this
is the best this is my chance to show
myself and the world what I'm made of
tell yourself that instantly you're
gonna find maybe you're not all the way
amped up ready to go but you're feeling
a little bit better than you were before
and all you need is that little tip that
little tiny bit of inspiration
to force you into action mode the point
of saying it's the best isn't just some
motivational pump up it's to get you the
courage to then take the action and do
the thing because all you need are those
few seconds of courage to take the
action to then make yourself proud the
goal of it's the best is to get you into
action mode
now what about bigger things what about
what about bigger problems well listen
when I broke my neck last year on my
tour right if you guys don't know the
story I broke my neck in two spots and
had a concussion and compressed my spine
and had all these issues
what did I do I told myself this is the
best it's the same strategy guys it's
the best this is my chance to show
myself in the world what I'm made of And
when everybody told me to go home on my
tour and just to line but I didn't relax
I finished my tour I only missed one
spot on my tour because I was in a
hospital in Colorado every other stop we
hit and I sat at the front with ice
packs for four hours answering questions
and doing my event was it the best event
uh no was I on top of my game as much as
before no but I finished it and it was
an inspiration to a lot of the people
who came out too they say I'm I'm
complaining about the guy who cut me off
in traffic on the way here and you're
sitting here with a broken neck at the
front doing the workshop like yep right
let's go it's the best and ultimately if
you step above it
if you believe like I believe that your
purpose comes from your pain
whatever happened to you you're that
deepest darkest moment in your life that
you never want to experience again that
you never want to go back to again that
that pain
that's your purpose
helping other people
never experience that pain helping other
people go through that pain and feel
like they're not alone like you were
alone that's your calling that's your
purpose for the rest of your life that
will fill you up for the rest of your
life for me helping entrepreneurs not
struggle as much as I struggled at the
beginning
will fill me up forever forever
your purpose comes from your pain and so
the greatest pain of all time that you
ever went through
it's the best
you could choose to be
overwhelmed by it that pain that happens
you will Define you one way or the other
either you continue to live in that pain
or try to forget that pain
and never live a fulfilled life or you
choose to serve and you choose to help
and choose to understand that there are
millions of people right now who are
struggling with that same thing and
they're suffering alone and they could
use your help
the best
so whether it's getting cut off in
traffic whether it's breaking your neck
on a tour
whether it's some crazy thing that
happened to you when you were younger
some painful moment
it's the best
it's the best and you try to catch it
and use that
as your three seconds of courage to then
take the action that would make you
proud because if you did that
consistently you start to catch it more
often you start to take those
complaining moments that you have even
if it's just complaining inside your
head maybe you're not complaining out
loud but you're complaining inside your
head you're about to give yourself a
break you're about to tell yourself to
go easy and have an excuse for not doing
something and then you wake up tomorrow
and you're not proud of yourself anymore
try to catch it today tomorrow this week
catch it catch it just once catch it and
say no
not this time this is the best this is
my chance to show myself in the world
what I am made of good luck rule number
six remind yourself of your greatness
reminding yourself every day of how
amazing you are I think it's one of the
greatest gifts you can give yourself and
it's not about ego it's about confidence
confidence comes from a place of
strength ego comes from a place of
weakness and insecurity so it's time to
step into your confidence and remind
yourself of how amazing you really are
this video is gonna help so I used to
have a lot of problems with with ego
versus confidence I used to feel like
who am I why do people need to hear my
story I was profiling all these
different successful entrepreneurs and
people kept asking well where are you
how come we can't see what you're about
where did you come from and I always
felt like my story doesn't matter I'm
profiling Diva Goggins and Steve Jobs
and and all these people why do you care
about I mean sure I sold my first
business had an exit but it's nothing
compared to what all these other people
have done and I always
shrouded it covered it under ego like
well that's such an egotistical thing to
do
but really I was just playing small I
was cheating people the opportunity to
learn to get better to grow from my
story that my story has value it's the
belief that my story had value that took
some time to really work up even making
videos on my channel
the number one most requested person for
top 10 was me and I resisted for maybe
two years of even making an Evan
Carmichael top 10 because I just felt
not good enough I felt like that's such
an ego play and not coming from a place
of confidence and yes my message has
impact has meaning can help the world
and the first Evan Carmichael top 10
came out from my team so my birthday
birthday I think it was my birthday
birthday or Christmas my team put
together with the with the support of my
hardcore fans my first top ten
and that's the one that that went live
on a channel and ever since then we've
done a regular series of me being on the
channel but it's it's been a real
progress for me it's been a real
Evolution it's taken me a long time and
hopefully you can get there faster this
has been almost 20 years of me sharing
ideas and content and and slowly
stepping into the light and slowly
building more confidence and more belief
and I hope that
with the content I'm making and the
experiences I'm sharing you can get
there a lot faster now I've got a
three-step process that I've gone
through that can shortcut that path to
confidence for you okay so my three-step
process how do you go from worrying
about being seen as too egotistical to
actually having real genuine confidence
here we go step number one is play
bigger triggers play bigger triggers are
things that you create in your
environment that remind you of who you
want to be of the best version of you
and so I've changed my camera angle
around for this week of film and hope
you guys like it you can see my
environment you can see more of it now
and so I've got play bigger triggers I
walk in and I see Steve Jobs and AP
giannini my favorite Entre of all time
my parents Howard Schultz Kanye West
even Kanye West is somebody who I hated
at the beginning because he seemed way
too egotistical for me but he says some
things that that makes sense that make
me better he's got a a picture of
himself when he when you walk into his
house he's got this giant picture of
himself which feels very egotistical but
how he explains this like if you're not
your own biggest fan first nobody else
is going to be your fan right so I love
it I've got Kanye on the wall I have my
uh my YouTube plaques there I've got a
mannequin wearing the believe hoodie
because I feel like a superhero putting
this on right the clothes you wear or
play bigger triggers the books here you
know the the the the the YouTube Awards
the Doritos bag even even
even this right like I wore I wore this
for for 60 days when I broke my neck and
I was gonna throw it away and my friend
Marc draker fan of the channel said keep
it like why would I keep it it's this
nasty duct tape you know neck
mask neck guard I don't know what it was
anyway to keep my neck in place so it's
a reminder and and when I look at it now
when I walk into the office
I feel awesome like I did that I I did
60 days in this and I took it off for 10
minutes every day and I continued on my
tour I didn't go home and I kept making
videos with a concussion a broken neck
and four is at the front of every
seminar that was putting on it sometimes
feels hard to remember that I did that
just now being back home and making my
content back on schedule it's hard to
remember that this I'm this guy I did
this
and so what are the play bigger triggers
for you from the clothes you wear from
the the what's on your desktop
background and your cell phone
background and the pictures on the wall
and the the things that you see every
day because you might have one day being
being inspired and motivated maybe after
watching this video you're ready to go
awesome but what do you have on The
Daily
and the beautiful thing about creating
an environment like this and having to
play bigger triggers around you is you
only set it up once you set it up once
and every day I'm working here my
computer's right here every day I got
Steve Jobs staring me down and you know
apgenini and my parents and this reminds
me every day of the best of who I am
and so same thing for you what's one
immediate change that you can make to
your environment that's a play bigger
trigger to remind you of the best of who
you are because the goal doesn't be the
next Steve Jobs or the next Kanye West
to next David Goggins is to take those
pieces to remind you to be the best of
you step number two is act on your
uncomfortable ideas we get great ideas
as entrepreneurs we get great ideas and
especially moments of boldness and
confidence and courage you get great
ideas it could be when you're in the
shower on an airplane or traveling you
get great ideas for what you want to do
and then tomorrow you tell yourself ah I
can't do that that's crazy that that's
too hard that's that's scary that's
uncomfortable
teach yourself to act on your crazy
ideas is how you start to build
confidence because if you come up
against a crazy idea and then you allow
yourself to say well that's too scary
that's too hard that's too difficult I
can't do that what you've taught
yourself is you don't have courage
you've taught yourself to come up with
ideas but then not trust in yourself and
so when you come up with the next idea
you're telling yourself I don't trust
myself when you set a goal for yourself
to hit hit some Big Goal you don't
believe yourself anymore because all
you've done is taught yourself that you
set goals you have ideas and you never
follow through you've built this
identity of I'm somebody who doesn't
follow through that's what you need to
start to destroy
that's where you need to destroy and
squash out of your life that identity of
I don't follow through your ideas are
genius your ideas are amazing this is
why play bigger curious and help you get
an idea and you're in your awesome
environment act on it do something lean
into the uncomfortable lean into the
things that cause a little bit of your
heart to beat and cause some anxiety
that's how you start to make the shift
and step number three is then celebrate
your effort celebrate your effort not
the results celebrate the effort that
you tried that you worked your hardest
that you did the uncomfortable thing
whether it worked out or not that you
came up with an idea to email somebody
who could be a potential dream client
for you maybe they didn't write back
maybe they did right back and they told
you you suck and I hate you I never want
to work with you
it's the willingness to go and do the
uncomfortable thing the the fact that
you did it that you tried
because that's the only thing that's
separating you from the David Goggins
from you from the person that you want
to be if you look at David goggin store
and being 300 pounds whatever way and
couldn't do anything it's the will to
get up and do it every day
and on a on a day by day basis there's
not a lot of growth if you've never done
something
and now it's your first day doing if
you've never made a video before and
it's your first day doing it guess what
the video is gonna suck you're supposed
to suck at the start that's okay that's
normal
but people judge themselves for sucking
at the beginning people judge themselves
for not getting the result right at the
beginning that's the mistake you
celebrate the effort
David Gaga is with 300 pounds overweight
and now is one of the best ultra
marathon runners in the world how does
that happen well it didn't happen on
this first run
and if he did his first run and then
said well I suck I'm not going to keep
going then guess what he never becomes
that ultra marathon runner same thing
for you
same thing for me go back and look at my
YouTube channel I'm
6 000 videos in is that six thousand
some crazy number videos in on my
channel go back and watch the first ones
I sucked compared to where I'm at now
and even right now I suck compared to
where I'm gonna be in 10 years if I keep
doing this right it's been 11 years on
the channel
if I do it for another 11 years I'm
gonna be even better in 11 years and
where I am right now
that's called progress that's normal
and so tying your self-esteem yourself
for with your self-confidence to the
willingness to go off and do it whether
you get the result or not because if
every day you get up and you start
working that hard and you're insanely
proud of your effort you are going to
get the results rule number seven Lee
leave your comfort zone every day
there's a battle raging inside you the
battle is between the Comfort version of
yourself and the growth version of
yourself the comfort you
wants to be comfortable doesn't want to
push wants to stay where you are it's
it's difficult it's scary out there
let's stay warm and comfortable and the
growth version of you
wants to grow wants to learn wants to
develop wants to progress wants to serve
wants to help and doing that requires
have encouraged boldness and jumping
into the unknown and it's a daily battle
it's a daily battle that never goes away
and you have to choose who consistently
is going to win and those daily battles
are not won by doing the big heroic once
a year things it's one by doing the
daily things the daily small things that
shift your identity forward to teach
yourself that your the growth kind of
person and not the Comfort kind of
person
the first time I met Brendan burchard
was at his event at growth.com I was
speaking in Phoenix it was his event I
was one of two guest speakers it was him
and his partner speaking and then me and
Eric Thomas and his business partner
invited me to come and speak
and it flew me down there and I'd never
met Brendan before I knew I knew of him
obviously uh but I didn't never met him
face to face and when I when I met him
he came backstage uh I think it was the
day before I was gonna go speak and I
met him backstage and he said hey I
can't I can't wait to to see you on
stage uh I almost never bring on guest
speakers who I haven't seen speak before
but you came highly recommended by my
business partner so let's do this and
I'm gonna watch your speech and
see what you do I have a TV interview
that I'm doing and I'm going to pause
that and make sure I'm done so I can
watch your speech so in my head there's
a lot of stress and pressure one I never
met Brendan before two there's a couple
thousand people out there in the
audience uh and three usually when
speakers are on stage the other speakers
aren't super paying attention you know
they're backstage in their own world
doing their own thing but Brendan was
gonna end his interview to make sure
that he was going to watch my speech and
so he's adding all this extra pressure
on me this is the Battle of of growth
versus comfort of growth Evan versus
Comfort Evan my biggest fear of
disappointing people I don't want to
disappoint him I don't want to
disappoint the person who paid me to be
there I don't want to disappoint the
couple thousand people in the audience
and so we go through these moments
where the comfort you takes over the
comfort you wants to play small wants to
quit wants it back down wants to find
and out wants to find an excuse for why
you can't do something and the growth
you is struggling for control
there's two things that I do that help
growth Evan come out and I want you to
internalize them to apply them to use
them because if you can use these two
strategies it can massively shift your
identity forward help you become the
growth version of you instead of the
Comfort version of you and start giving
you the results you want as well as a
more purposeful happy life of service
two things first one
take on the identity that you do
difficult things
you do difficult things that if
something is scary or difficult or hard
that it's not a good enough reason that
you do scary you do difficult you love
hard
and so I use those as triggers and why
it's important is you shortcut the
thinking pattern every time that you say
that it's scary there's difficult that
it's hard or whatever words that you use
that give yourself a break that let
yourself off the hook use those as
trigger words the fact that you set it
means you have to do it
the fact that you said it you thought it
you wrote it means you have to do it
just because
what it does is it shortcuts the excuse
because what normally happens is you say
well that's that's too difficult you've
accepted that difficult is a good enough
reason for you to play small you don't
go and do the thing
you've accepted any excuses that come
into your head over why you can't do it
they're not you don't call them excuses
you call them you call them reasons
right logical valid reasons why you
can't do it
I want to shortcut all that I don't want
to even allow you to go there because I
don't allow myself to go there the fact
that I said scary difficult Hearts mean
I have to do it
so find your trigger words you can use
mine as a starting point if you want but
find your trigger words and that becomes
your new identity
you want to take on the identity that
you do difficult things
that you you jump into the unknown
that those are no longer good enough
reasons for you and so I did this when I
was backstage when I'm my heart's
beating uh I'm I'm I forgot what I was
gonna say going on stage like in the
moments leading up to going on stage I
forgot what I was gonna say I have no
slides either on stage right I don't go
with a PowerPoint presentation there's
one slide that just has my my name and
face on it that's it no slides as if I
forget what I'm gonna say God is screwed
so breathe I Evan Carmichael does
difficult things I do difficult things
right you remind yourself what that does
is put you into a more resourceful state
to go and actually solve the problem
so that's step one you do difficult
things and and again it's not just the
big hero moments it's the micro there's
difficult things that have happened
already today that you have not done
what you need to do
because it was difficult and you give
yourself an out go do it what that does
to your self-love for your self-pride
for your self-respect for your
self-confidence is incredible
and and you need to give yourself that
gift I want you to give yourself that
gift every day of doing a difficult
thing and for you something that's
difficult may seem trivial or small for
somebody else when I broke my neck and
and was struggling with a concussion
getting out of bed
was difficult
just getting out of bed and putting my
feet on the ground and standing up was
incredible pain through my spine
incredible pain which is something I
take for granted now but that was
difficult
and so when when those things happen you
pat yourself on the back you did it you
did the difficult thing so that's step
number one you do difficult things
the second mindset shift is leaning into
service
it's even about you newsflash it's not
about you
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're you're for all the Ambitions that
you have for yourself whatever the thing
is that you're afraid to do usually the
thing we're afraid to do is in front of
somebody else you're not afraid of
failing you're afraid of failing and
who's going to see you fail
right you will sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner why
people will film videos at in home at
their home but not film it on the street
where people can see them because you're
afraid of being watched
you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people
you need to stop being selfish
get out of your own head and recognize
that you're here to serve you're here to
help you've got a message knowledge
information that can help people and by
you playing small you're doing a
disservice to them and to yourself
and so that's the other thing that I'll
lean into is yeah Evan Carmichael does
difficult things but also I'm here to
serve and so when I'm backstage and I'm
I know Brennan's gonna watch me I know
thousands of people are watching me and
afraid of disappointing everybody I look
out into the audience and instead of
seeing 2 000 people who are here to
judge me and I'm going to disappoint
them
I'm here looking at them saying I have a
message that can help them
I'm here to serve them because what I'm
going to share
Brendan doesn't know
Eric Thomas doesn't know the other
speakers here his Partners they don't
know I can share something unique that
can help them and my my intention is
good I'm here to help these people not
rip them off not leave them down a dark
path I'm here to help them and that
again shifts how you feel about yourself
to give you the Courage the boldness the
motivation the power to go and then do
the thing that the growth version of you
needs that's how you get out of the
comfort zone that's how you get out of
comfort you scared you small you into
powerful you bold you courageous you
growth you
number one you do difficult things
anytime you find yourself complaining
scary difficult hard negative you do
difficult things and number two you're
here to serve
you're here to serve you're here to help
you're trying to do good and keeping
your gifts to yourself is selfish and
you have to share it and get it out
there those two things on a daily basis
on a daily basis every single day that's
that battle raging inside your head
between the growth you and the comfort
you and my ambition my intention my goal
for you
is to have growth you win a little bit
more than comfort you it's not going to
be 100 growth to you there's no way
that's going to happen don't make that
Perfection the bar it's at every day
growth you wins at least 51 of the
battles versus comfort you you do that
your life will change room number eight
eight chief goal officer influencing
someone starts with you being their
chief goal officer that is your job be
their chief goal officer you have to
understand what their values are you
have to understand what their Ambitions
are you have to understand who they are
before you can influence them the worst
advice that you can give somebody this
is this is a challenge a lot of leaders
face when they're building an
organization the worst advice you can
give somebody is what you would do the
worst advice you can give somebody is
what you would do because they're not
you because they have different values
because they have different Ambitions
because they want a different path than
what you've taken and so if you just say
here's what I would do and then you come
off and feeling like you're a hero and a
genius you've maybe screwed them over
and so you need to start by being a
chief goal officer if people are not
listening to you if people are not
following your orders and people do not
respect you is because you're giving
them wrong advice because you have not
done the work to be their chief goal
officer and then help them accomplish
what they want to accomplish and figure
out the best path for them okay so how
do you become somebody's chief goal
officer I'm going to give you three ways
to do it step number one is know their
one word in Credo your one word is your
most important core value the thing that
you stand on and the Creator or the
three things that make up that Define
what that one word is for the people
when I first wrote the book your one
word I didn't anticipate it being a
leadership book I thought it'd be just
something that you use for yourself but
it's shocking how many people now buy
the book and give it to their team so
you get a window of what your team's
core values are so you know how to move
and Inspire them as an example if
they're one word if somebody in your
team's one word is freedom then it gives
you a window of how to handle that
person they don't want to be
micromanaged they'd want to be told what
to do 24 7. they need to have some
freedom in their decision making and
controls so they can go off and do their
job so they they can express themselves
so that they can have fun and be happy
the more you are handcuffing them the
more they feel like you're putting them
in a jail the more you're gonna lose and
you're not going to influence them so
step number one is figure out for
everyone on your team what are their one
words and credos step number two is what
are their Ambitions what do they want
what do they want to accomplish are they
trying to make a lot of money are they
trying to move to another country are
they trying to learn some certain skills
like what do they want what are they
here for what do they try to get because
yes they're here to do a job yes you
want them to figure out how to do XYZ
because you have a business Target and
you're trying to accomplish that thing
awesome they're a human being they're
not a robot they're not a monkey they're
not just typing things in for you so you
can accomplish your goals you have your
goals and they have their own set of
goals and if you are not being their
chief goal officer if you do not
understand saying what their Ambitions
are then you're gonna lose then you're
gonna give them tasks that they don't
want to do anymore that they're going to
grow and learn and want to expand and
you don't know how they want to expand
and they're going to quit and they're
going to leave you and you're not gonna
be able to push them forward you have to
do the job of figuring out how if they
want to go here this is their ambition
and they're here right now you have to
make that path visible you have to show
them how they can go from here to here
and then you put everything that they're
doing in that light
so this is the path I want you to get
here too I know you want to be here I
want you to get here here's how to get
there and they may not see it because
they haven't experienced it yet they may
not be able to tie the dots together to
say oh if I do this I'll be able to get
there that's your job help them be their
Chief Bill officer understand their
Ambitions step number two and then step
number three is how can you run parallel
pass together so it's pretty unlikely
that somebody on your team will stay
with you forever they have Ambitions
they have goals they want to get
somewhere and if you understand what
their goals are and you know where you
want to go then great you're running
this parallel path together and that
parallel path might be for three months
it might be for a year it might be for
six years or it might be forever but at
some point they want to go off and do
something else you're a stepping stone
for them to get somewhere else and
that's awesome you should celebrate that
don't fear that celebrate that and then
figure out how you can be a part of
their success how you can run that
parallel path together and then when
they're ready push them away like you're
ready you should go off and do that
thing now go do that thing you're right
ready you shouldn't be with me anymore
figure out how you can run the parallel
paths together and then help them go and
be the person that they want to be once
they've hit the end of the road with you
so that's a three-step process to being
someone's chief goal officer one figure
out what their one word and Credo are to
figure out what their Ambitions are and
then three figure out how can you run
parallel paths together rule number nine
raise your environment you become who
you consistently hang around with who
you spend the majority of your time with
both people who you actually physically
meeting and connecting with and hanging
out with and what you feed into your
brain that's how you start to think
that's how you start to behave that's
how you start to act think about your
mindsets your belief systems it comes
from the people who you're consistently
around so if you want to change your
life you want to change your direction
you're tired of living where you are
you're tired of your situation right now
the fastest way to change it is to
change who you start to associate with I
remember when
I first got started on my
entrepreneurial career I always felt
like I was kind of a dummy
um
I was a slow learner in school I never
got I never I didn't fail out of class
but I never got the Straight A's you
know that my sisters kept getting and
what I realized was I'm not dumb I just
need the right models and the right
mentors I had a different way of
learning than a lot of people and when I
started to figure that out I was like
I'm not I'm not an idiot I'm not dumb I
can't do this but I need to be around
the people who are doing it because
because when I can get that mentorship
when I can get that learning style down
then I can do amazing things that's it
that's the only difference the only
difference is I just don't have the
right people around me and I learned
that lesson over and over and over and
over again that when I just try to
figure it out myself I usually don't win
when I'm doing a structured learning
style like in a classroom setting I also
usually don't win but when I can
surround myself with the people who are
doing it and get the the coaching and
mentorship and guidance that I need I
can go I can win I can actually do stuff
Revelation I'm not
a devil was growing up and so how do you
do it how do you actually start to be
around the people who are inspiring you
lifting you up I'm gonna I'm gonna share
three strategies that I think will help
okay the first is actual people in your
life so you start the audit the people
in your life how much are the people in
your life building you up making you
believe in yourself giving you
encouragement giving you support giving
you love telling you that you can do it
how many people do you have like that in
your life probably not a lot most of us
probably don't have that many people
and so you want to immediately cut out
the people who are not giving you that
hope and encouragement or at least
spending less time with them because
maybe that's your mom right so spending
less time or or not talking about your
career or your business with the people
who don't support you and then injecting
more the people who do and fighting to
find ways to spend more time with the
people who lift you up and make you feel
like things are possible fighting to
spend more time with them I have an
expression that I use where I like to go
I like to collect good people I like the
collective people like to have people
around me that make me feel great and
when I find somebody I fight to try to
spend more time with them whether it's
start a business with them whether
that's do a monthly call with them think
about who's made you feel the best who
is somebody that you know and it
probably isn't your parents or close
family members or somebody in in the
outer ring of your circle how can you
now regularly spend more time with them
an easy starting point is a monthly
coffee how can you have a monthly copy
with them to talk about your business
ideas and where you're going so you want
to try to inject more of that positivity
into your circle into your group into
your life step number two is
the aspirational people that you may
never meet but you can be surrounded by
so if you love Warren Buffett hey maybe
maybe Warren Buffett's not going to sit
down with you for a monthly coffee to
chat about your business and your ideas
but
there's his videos there's his books
there's lots of stuff on YouTube you can
start with my channel there's a lot of
content that you can learn if you
watched a Warren Buffett video every day
guess what's going to happen you're
gonna have to think like him you're
going to start to adopt his mindset his
mentality you're gonna you're gonna take
on his belief systems a little bit more
and so the more you're around Warren
Buffett the more you're going to start
to process things like him and think
like him and so you may never meet him
for all the people who are watching and
say well I don't know anybody who's had
success okay well you don't need to but
you can still learn from the people
who've done it
that's the beauty of YouTube right now
that's that's everything that I've
learned I learned I learned how to get
out of the hole I was in my first
business by learning from Bill Gates I
still have never met Bill Gates but he
saved my company because I learned from
his story because I was willing to at
that time read books now I would much
prefer to watch videos and to to read
books on the topic but however you learn
videos books podcasts Your Heroes are
making content be around them more be
around them more because they will lift
you up they will make you feel like
things are possible when the people
around you are telling you all the
reasons why you're not going to win and
then step number three is is join some
kind of group join some kind of group
some kind of community some kind of
connection where you can be around
like-minded people the one that I use a
lot is my movement makers program so
inside movement makers we meet every two
weeks talking about a different tactic
to grow your movement and also
connecting people together it becomes a
family
when you're the only one in your circle
doing something man it's so hard to keep
going to keep the motivation to to be
the person who's constantly lifting
other people up who's doing that for you
so whether it's movement makers or some
other program get into one where you're
around your peers when you're around
people who are also trying to do big
things when you're around somebody else
who's trying to have a big impact and
change the world and when you're saying
even language like that you know if I'm
talking about I want to build something
that's changed the world you know most
of the people shopping here at Costco
like when who's this crazy guy you can't
do that right that's most of the people
around us but when you find your tribe
of people who are also trying to do
something big something scary something
crazy you start to feel like this is
possible finally yes right and so with
those movement makers are something else
to get a part of a network of people
your peers so in the early the first two
bits of advice you're learning from
people who are who've done more than you
but being just around peers who are
doing the same thing saying maybe in a
different industry but they're they're
trying to chase down their goals you can
motivate each other so that when you're
feeling down they they give you a little
bit of extra jet fuel and and you do the
same for them you fill them up when they
need it because that little extra bit
can make the difference between you
quitting and you going off and spending
one more day and that one day might be
the difference between you
building a giant company or working at
some job that you hate for the rest of
your life and so your Heroes really
matter the people you surround yourself
with really matters there's only so much
you can do completely by yourself
you know the fastest way to win is to is
to model success and so you can do that
you can do that if you follow those
three steps if you start to weed out the
people from your life who are just
filling with negativity and spend more
time with good people learn to collect
good people if you learn from your
aspirational mentors and you watch their
videos make it part of your daily
routine that's why I make so much
content because there's always somebody
you can learn from
but there's no excuse we I don't know
how many videos we do every single day a
lot of different videos every single day
why because there's no excuse now for
you not to be surrounded by Your Heroes
to learn something from them to be
educated by them to be inspired by them
every single day whether it's my videos
or something else to inject that as part
of your daily routine in the morning it
really really matters and then three to
join a group some kind of peer group be
around people who are doing things that
you can lean on and ask for their
support and that you can you can support
them as well when they need the help you
do those three things
your life will change rule number 10 the
last one
last one tube I feel like this is my
moment I feel like I know what I'm doing
I feel like I have my window however
long it's going to last it could be six
months 12 months 24 months I got to push
as hard as I can I feel like we're
really hitting it I think it's a great
combination of everything that I love
doing my skill sets my interest my
passion right now to provide value to
myself and to you guys and so that's why
I'm pushing hard I'm making three videos
a day
I go to my website
I had a shift where I said you know what
I want to solve the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential what
does that look like I don't know
when I first launched it I had no idea I
deleted my entire website threw up one
picture and that was my home page if you
go right now you'll see it's still a
bunch of pictures I had a little bit
more meat to the bones but I still don't
know where it's going I don't have all
the answers around it I'm still trying
to figure it out but I figure it out by
doing by testing by having conversations
and so from a SEO perspective my website
sucks but I wasn't interested in the
direction I was going anymore
I switched and so I had to find a way to
get started and so I did it myself
my website has now what I call the
circle potential and all those points
you can click on it and dive a little
bit deeper somebody made a comment
when you clicked on the first version of
my self-awareness button you said well
it's only promoting your stuff it should
have a wider range
you're right
I don't know the answer yet
I'm figuring it out
and so I don't let the fear of making
mistakes prevent me from doing anything
because if I waited until I had the
whole thing figured out what the perfect
website would look like I'd never launch
it and having a website that's not
complete
and building some momentum with it
drives me to want to do more on it
drives me when I figure out more details
on it and so some pages are more worked
out than others but all of them need a
lot more work
and it just came from that initial idea
that initial thesis
that as soon as you have an idea for
something you find immediate ways to
take action on it because the momentum
is so so so so so so so important the
biggest risk of all is not taking any
risk at all
I think comparing yourself to others is
actually fantastic I think most people
aren't even doing it enough the
challenges people do it incorrectly the
problem is people compare themselves to
others as a way to kick themselves down
you look at somebody else who's done a
lot more than you and you say wow
they're so much better than me I can
never do it and that's kicking yourself
down what you need to do
you flip it and say wow that person has
done so much that's what's possible I'm
comparing my beginning to their middle
or to their end which is an unfair
comparison they can get there therefore
I can go chase my dreams down as well
that's a kick forward most people kick
themselves down what you need is to kick
forward but without the kick you stay
stuck
if you want to say exactly where you are
don't compare yourself to anybody you
want to move forward compare yourself in
a loving way forward there's a classic
story of Roger Bannister who broke the
four minute mile where it was supposed
to be impossible to break the four
minute mile nobody was ever supposed to
be able to do it and then he did it and
everybody thought your body would break
down and that it just would never ever
ever happen and then Roger Bannister did
it and then what happened lots of other
people did it high school kids did it
people around the world have done it why
because they saw somebody else do it
when you can compare yourself to
somebody else and see that they can do
it that can be the inspiration to move
yourself forward again the kick forward
if you just look at that and say wow
he's superhuman I could never do it then
you're right you stay stuck but some
people the people who go off and win the
people who also have a happier life look
at that and say I can do something
similar
and people did
I actually heard about that Roger
Bannister story through Les Brown and
when people ask me who is my favorite
motivational speaker who who do you
think is the greatest speaker of all
time I say Les Brown
I don't I don't know who touches Les
Brown I mean there's so many great
speakers so many amazing people out
there I've had a The Good Fortune of
connecting with a lot of them but man
Les Brown when he gets on a tear it's
something different he takes you to a
different world and I remember when I
first heard him it's like holy cow this
guy is so good I know it's at the start
of my career of filming videos and
making content and I thought how does he
how does he know those
grips and how does he memorize those
lines and how does he
does he speak for an hour and not need
notes or a PowerPoint or anything else
like this man is crazy it's impossible I
could never get that good
and I used to compare myself in a
negative way like I could never be less
brown
and then somewhere along the line I
flipped it to say hey
I'm getting better
and I love what Les is doing because
he's actually guiding the industry
because it's actually showing what's
possible that if he can do it then I can
do it too he's actually Paving the way
for people like me to come up and be
speakers as well
and I actually had a The Good Fortune of
last week being on
a Facebook live with him where he was
interviewing me about my story like what
Les Brown is interviewing me about my
story is crazy how did this happen
because I used him
as an inspirational kick forward
see if you never see anybody who's like
you doing it it's really really hard to
get up and do
if you're the only person that you know
on your family and the only person that
you know in your community the only
person you see online anywhere trying to
do the thing that you want to do it's
really really really really really hard
to stay motivated but when you can see
somebody else when you can model success
when you can have an example to follow
I think that makes the path easier
because it gives you more hope knowing
that it's possible the trick is again
the key is again that in the comparison
of somebody else you're kicking yourself
forward to say that's what's possible
not down to say I suck you can get
credit almost any skill almost any skill
you could get great at if you wanted to
if you dedicated yourself to practicing
if you dedicated yourself to modeling
success if you dedicated yourself to
doing it you could get great at almost
any skill now
you know where people go with this is
the the extreme like well I I can't
become
you know seven footer in the NBA like
okay great if you're 5'2 you know you
might not be able to be a seven foot in
the NBA right but but just think about
it think about your goals think about
your dreams think about where you want
to go
what you want to do is possible
stop looking at all the the rare
exceptions of how you can't do it and
they said focus on how you can
[Music]
where we struggle is because the things
that we need to get great at
we probably aren't very good at that
this is a really deal for entrepreneurs
because you're probably good at some
things you're probably naturally good at
some things or you had some training or
your parents put you into classes and
you developed a skill set at something
but you may not like
[Music]
Electric
we're good at things that we don't like
doing
you're probably really good at a lot of
things that you don't want to actually
now commit the rest of your life to
doing
and so this creates the Dilemma this
creates an entrepreneur's dilemma
we should name it something maybe it's
the entrepreneur's Dilemma where
you have two choices you either focus on
what you're good at that can get you
paid that can get you a job that can
maybe even have you start your business
you're good at it you can get paid doing
it but it is not something you enjoy and
the more you do it you Soul you slowly
start to lose your soul it slowly starts
to be life sucking for you like imagine
this thing that you're good at that you
don't like doing just imagine you close
your eyes you're daydreaming imagine
that you had to do this thing for the
next 40 Years of your life
how much would you hate your life if you
keep doing those things
so it's that you keep doing the things
that you're good at but you don't like
versus the things that you want to be
good at that you really love but right
now you suck at it
that's the hardest thing for people it's
like you want to get good at this other
thing that's where your passion is
that's where your heart is but you don't
have the skills yet and so a lot of
entrepreneurs where they quit this is
where a lot of you will quit you'll quit
you'll stop because you're not good at
it it's like oh wow I suck at it
and so I guess I'll never be good at it
and so then you don't do it where all
you need to do is flip it to say okay I
don't suck as a human
I don't I don't I'm not good at the
skill set yet but it can get good at it
how do I get good get good at it is by
practicing
when I first started making videos
everything is against me right if you
look at who I was where I came from my
personality my thought process
everything was against me for making
videos so let me let me break it down
let me actually take you into the early
days of Evan Carmichael making YouTube
videos I am shy
I am introverted uh I don't like
disappointing people I have no need to
be famous you know I don't I don't like
the spotlight I actually would rather be
at the back of the room instead of you
know on stage
all of this doesn't sound good for
somebody who's
then gonna go make videos turning on the
camera terrified me uh I'm filming here
in a parking lot right or my wife is
shopping at Costco there
um I would never be able to do this you
know there's people walking by this
would this would freak me out
I would say who's that who's that crazy
guy in the car doing that thing you know
on paper I guess everything looked like
it was against me I made a video
because I had this idea to make a video
because I'm a visual learner
I think your purpose comes from your
pain
I struggled so much as an entrepreneur I
wanted to make the road a little bit
easier for other entrepreneurs
and so I made one video
and it was it was not the greatest
experience
I was terrified I was sitting down I was
in a suit I was nervous I was memorizing
a script because I was so worried that I
was gonna say the wrong words and people
wouldn't like my video they can go back
and watch the first one I did on Walt
Disney and it took a day or whatever to
make this one short video and I'm not
even on camera for most of it most of it
is me doing an audio because I could I
could read it I wanted to read the
script that had the perfect script
and there was b-roll on top of it there
was very little of me actually on camera
but even those few lines I had on camera
was terrified and I was trying to
memorize and I was sweating and I was
funny sitting down in the suit all that
was hilarious
I wasn't very good at it
I wasn't very good at it but there was
something about it that I just liked
I liked it I liked the idea none of it
made sense right again there was no
option to be YouTube famous nobody was
YouTube famous uh in in education in
2009 when I first started it didn't
exist
and my personality of being introverted
child that did not lend itself well to
being a personality
but for some reason even everything was
seemingly against me on paper I just I
liked it
and I wasn't very good at it but I
thought you know what I can get better
I'm gonna keep doing this thing
and it took me
you could see my stats and I posted off
into to my Instagram once a month it's
an update of how my channel is doing
from the first video that I posted it
took five years to get to 9 000
subscribers
five years to get the 9 000 subscribers
a lot of you guys are already way ahead
of that after your first year of just
making content
you're already ahead
and then I went five years again from
the 9000 to 2 million
see there's a person next to me right
now
try to film her this would freak me out
I'm gonna be filming here making a video
with this person's right next to me how
he should judge me what is she thinking
what is she doing you know I get super
distracted I wouldn't be able to film
content
so it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself
embarrassed like I couldn't watch back
my own videos they were too painful to
watch I would look at it I would judge
myself I would criticize myself I would
I would say man you're still not very
good I would find a million things that
was wrong with the video just so many so
many things that
I was not happy with
350 public videos guys 350 and then I
took 700 videos until I inspired myself
until I watched it back I said man I'm
you know what this I I'm starting to get
decent at this you know there's
something there maybe maybe I have a
future here
700 public videos later it's crazy so
what what kept me through it what kept
me
consistent how did I keep going because
the mission yes of of wanting to help
serve entrepreneurs but also I liked I
liked it I liked the process of doing it
there was something again even though it
didn't make sense
for someone like me to do it I liked it
it was fun and so I kept going and you
know now we're over 10 000 videos later
still making content still doing it and
not burning out because I like the
process if you love what you're doing
you're not going to burn out happiness
down to fulfillment versus excitement
when people ask me hey Evan how do you
how do you define happiness is one of
the most common questions I get asked
when I'm doing interviews and podcasts
and such what does happiness look like
to you well happiness
is fulfillment and excitement
because it's very interesting word so
let's break it down
fulfillment is feeling like what you do
matters
you're happy when you feel like what you
do matters you're happy when you feel
like you wake up today and today is
going to matter this is what we all want
we all want to feel like what we're
going to do today is going to have an
impact on somebody else's life we are
all built to serve you want to feel
important to somebody else not just from
a ego perspective that oh I matter and
I'm important but in a way that you
contributed to somebody else's life
we're all connected we want to feel
connected we want to feel like this is
going to matter today that this video
that I make for you even though I'm here
just in the car by myself well Nina's
actually Nina's back there hello Nina
even though I'm just here filming by
myself in the car I want to feel like
this video is touching somebody it's
touching you that you guys are watching
it and hopefully the message here is
going to be inspiring and helpful to you
in some way we all want that that's
fulfillment right if you wake up too
many days in a row and you feel like
today doesn't matter if nobody cares if
I show up nobody cares if I do a good
job or not nobody cares that's a fast
path to depression and worst case
suicide right that's where a lot of
people unfortunately are living right
now is they don't feel like they matter
they're not happy because there's no
fulfillment
they're not happy because they feel like
they don't matter to anybody
so that's fulfillment the other side of
happiness is excitement you're happy
when you feel like you're doing
something new you're happy when you get
to try something new you get to have fun
you get to do something that hasn't been
done before you're you're you're going
out of your comfort zone or you're
you're having this quick hit right I
mean it could be anything from I'm
excited to have my coffee yeah I'm
excited to have my Starbucks you know
when we go once a week to film we get a
Starbucks put some cream in and I'm
excited for the taste right you could be
excited for that donor that meal you
know it may not even be good for you the
Donut's not good for you but you're
still excited to have it because it
tastes so good you're chasing this
little momentary high or you could be
excited to go on that vacation you're
excited just something new this it's a
it's a moment in time
it's the little it's the candy it's the
sweets
right and it's the sweets of life
it's not sustainable but it's not
designed to be sustainable
it's these little moments in time that
make us happy and that's true too but
that's why it's excitement
jumping from an airplane you know it's
exciting
it's not sustainable
you guys show up every day and and fall
from the airplane all day long right and
so I think where a lot of people
struggle a lot of entrepreneurs
especially is we're chasing the
excitement only you're you're chasing
what's going to feel like when you hit
your goal when you have a million
subscribers or a million in revenue or
whatever success looks like to you
well what we're missing is the
Fulfillment part of it there's nothing
wrong with chasing those goals there's
nothing wrong with having that caffeine
high that Sugar Rush that you know hey I
hit my goal amazing there's nothing
wrong with it but if that's all there is
you need the meal
right if that's all there is you're
never actually going to be happy because
those are just moments in time
that you're you get excited today if
that something happened and then you
might wait another month before the next
exciting thing happens we're just
Adrenaline Junkies is what entrepreneurs
are a lot of entrepreneurs just become
Adrenaline Junkies chased in the next
High
that's not sustainable That's not
healthy and that's not ultimate
happiness
you have to pair it with the Fulfillment
when you can do both
that I'm I'm chasing these big goals
these Big Dreams or even something small
I can do right now to get excited and
pairing it with what I do matters this
is fulfilling to me this is going to
make a difference in somebody's life
that's where I think you have long-term
sustainable healthy forms of happiness
the good news is both of them you can
accomplish right now
at any point in time
you could choose to help somebody you
could choose to go serve somebody right
at any point in time it could be you
know helping those people put the
groceries in their car right they could
go go help them or take the shopping
cart and and put it away for them random
act of kindness it could be going to
somebody's YouTube comments and leaving
a nice message think about a creator
that you like to follow somebody else
that you subscribe to who maybe doesn't
have as big a following go leave a nice
message how long does it take you to do
right 18 seconds you just made a
difference in somebody's life
[Music]
responding to somebody who follows you
on Instagram and saying hey thank you
for following me on Instagram I really
appreciate you that's how I built my
Instagram following I'd be sitting here
at a Costco
individually messaging people who
followed me to say hey Rick hey Susan
hey Jennifer thank you so much for
following me I really appreciate you
thank you send next right seven seconds
eight seconds 15 seconds at a time
you can choose at any point to be happy
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there my favorite question to ask
somebody who I respect and I want to
learn from is please tell me why I suck
it might seem a little crazy it might
seem